ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dylan show we have a really exciting
episode today Noah tishby is here uh she
is the uh big Israel Advocate she was
just profiled in the New York Times and
we talked to her uh some news on the
book I am switching Publishers we did
not really get along these are things
that happen I'm not a huge fan of people
editing me so um we're trying to work it
out where we can keep some of the pre
the pre-sales I don't know if we can so
you all may get refunded and then just
there'll be no other pre-sales you just
come buy the book when it's out in the
spring um um but we couldn't really
hammer out an agreement on what I wanted
so um that's the way it is you know it's
like hey who cares um so go out we'll
see you I'll do a little book tour in
the spring we'll be out talking about
the book uh this is an interesting
episode Noah knows a lot about Israel
she's a fierce advocate of Israel and a
staunch defender of Israel and I'm sure
there's a lot of people that will agree
with her there's a lot of people that
will disagree with her it's a very good
conversation very respectful I
appreciate her taking the time to speak
with us so without further Ado here is
Noah Tish ladies and gentlemen welcome
to the Tim Dylan show special guest here
Noah
Tish uh I pronounced that right um I
became aware of you a few weeks ago when
you were on your Instagram page uh
talking about what's going on in the
Middle East um and I read a little bit
about you you are very accomplished
person um you worked for Benjamin
netanyahu's government nope no well
that's for very briefly but we'll get to
that in a second okay I wasn't
completely I'm not completely I was
appointed I was appointed so I'm a I'm a
I'm Israeli American I was born born and
raised in Israel um I was a an actress
and a producer I first I brought the
first television show to the United
States and treatment uh sold it to HBO
it was the first television format to
ever make it to Israel to America from
Israel
I have been an Israel Advocate and a
Jewish Advocate and worked in the
anti-Semitism space for a very long time
I started the first online advocacy rep
response organization uh in 2011 and in
um last year I was appointed by yair
Leed actually uh to be Israel's first
special Envoy for combating
anti-Semitism and
delegitimization and I worked for the
Leed Bennett government which was the
quote unquote the good government in
terms of the um uh American kind of left
and progressives and uh then the new
government got in which is much more uh
right-wing and much more religious and I
still said I was going to I wanted to
continue working because I feel like the
space of anti-Semitism is more important
than any politics and then I critized
the uh attempt in a Judicial overhaul in
Israel and was relieved from my position
so I can I I can say that I worked for
the Netanyahu government for a couple of
months briefly very and you were
dismissed I was dismissed so you were a
Critic of the right-wing uh what you
felt was right-wing overreach of the
Netanyahu government which is which is
the perfect example of how you can you
can criticize Israeli government
policies while acknowledging that Israel
has the right to exist as a Jewish state
which is what we are actually here to
discuss right what in your estimation
what has the media gotten
wrong about the narrative about what has
happened since the Mass Attack oh the
question is what did the media get wrong
in the past like 25 years or or even
more so first of all let's go back for a
second on October 7th Israel was invaded
not by like a couple acute terrorists
which is when we say a terrorist attack
you kind of think you know 5 6 10 19
like we had here in September 11th what
people need to understand is that Israel
was invaded by nearly 3,000 terrorists
not give or take so it's a battalion
it's essentially a mil military that
attacked Israel from the south broke the
Border down and uh invaded cities and
towns and kibuts with the clear orders
to murder Slaughter rape torture and
kidnap as many people as they possibly
can the stories the photos the videos
that are coming out of it so they not
only did they create like they caused
the greatest Slaughter and Massacre on
the Jewish people since the Holocaust in
one day so 1500 now people men women and
children were were slaughtered that day
the level of barbar barbarism and sadism
is beyond the pale and they filmed it so
their intention was to show the world
and the Jewish Community what it is that
they're capable and willing to do I
can't that there was there's the the
beheading of babies the burning of fames
up alive there was a I'm I'm sorry to be
graphic but I'm I'm just going to have
to be there's a there was a 30-year-old
woman who was pregnant they sliced her
belly open they pulled out the F fetus
and they beheaded that fetus such that
they literally I mean it's
inhuman torturing families next to the
children P like it's unbelievable right
right and this is something that
Israel's been dealing with in a very
small scale for a very long time so
there's this culture of radical Islam
radical Islamic Nazism basically that is
not interested what we in the west think
that they're interested in so what
they're not interested is a two-state
solution what they're not interested is
um living peacefully side by side what
they're not interest in anything that we
hold dear as our Western values and this
is one of the things that I've been
trying to warn for against for a very
long time and a lot of us has because we
you you think that you can the the
American um specifically like the Left
Right is creating some sort of a
projection they're projecting their
values on the region and they're saying
oh well certainly everybody just wants
to live in peace like certainly every
mother just wants the children to grow
up and have a great future and as a
liberal Living in America when I moved
from Israel to here it was very
challenging for me to see that a lot of
people don't get that they don't get
that no not everybody has the same
culture so but this is also many many
years no to answer your question about
the media the re I also um uh I wrote a
book a a couple years ago it came out
and it's it's called Israel A Simple
Guide to the most misunderstood country
on earth and the reason I wrote that
book is because I realized that there's
no no book that tells the story of
Israel in a way that's easy to
understand that's like fun that's funny
God forbid right and I literally wrote
that book because the media was getting
Israel wrong all the time and that is I
mean the book is selling again really
well and people are finding it now
because everything that's happening
right now including the media including
universities including all of it is is
written in the book because it's been
something that I've been working on for
a long time time there has been and is
an anti-israel media bias that as an
Israeli and an American Jew right is
kind of funny when people keep blaming
the Jews for having a media cabal well
aren't there a lot of Jews that work in
the media a lot of Jews working in a
field doesn't equate control of the
field no for sure so here's where
anti-Semitism jumps in which is
anti-Semitism is anti-jewish racism it's
where you have this subconscious bias
again against the other a people right
blacks and Asians and whatever you're
kind of like suspicious about them got
with
anti-Semitism it's not simple racism so
it's not you don't don't just look down
at something or someone you look up at
them a little bit so anti-Semitism in
essence is a shape-shifting conspiracy
theory and the conspiracy theory sounds
like yeah these [__] Jews they
control everything right right so when
you think to yourself for real that the
Jews control everything and a lot of
your viewers and listen right now are
like well don't they that is a
conspiracy theory and that is what
allows later on for your opinions to be
about Israel to be completely skewed so
if you think that the Jews control
everything then of course Israel is the
big bad wolf because like the Jews
control everything and we're sitting
there going we are the worst [__]
cabal in the world now it was very funny
to some extent but now it's not funny
anymore well no for sure but is it is
there a space like you said to be
critical of maybe the settler program
the expansionism of uh you know moving
yeah here's the thing yeah you can be a
republican a Democrat a Libertarian it
doesn't matter what right none of us
love the policies of putting kids in
cages
right in the border right nobody well it
was liberal Jews have been the ones
who've advocated on behalf of having a
lot of immigration wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait wait pause
pause for a second that's another wait
just a second nobody is for any there
are policies in America that we don't
love right sure nobody's talking about
dismantling
America right but I don't think any
serious people are talking about
dismantling Israel think so are you
seeing what's happening on colleges I
literally had the same argument with
Bill Mar and he's like no and I'm like
the colleges have gone insane but that's
the young American Minds that are going
around and saying from The River To The
Sea Palestine will be free and they're
saying something like this and this is
something that I've noticed like 10
years ago right the conversation about
Israel in certain circles turned from
Poli IES BB Netanyahu yes or no
settlements yes or no policies which is
totally legit to have a conversation
about something that sounded like this
right yeah but like is Israel a real
State though or is it like a colonialist
settler Endeavor that needs to be
dismantled then that is something that
can't we can't allow to happen Israel is
the only country that you have a debate
on whether or not it should exist insane
I don't know of any serious person that
I know of that has said Israel doesn't
have a right to exist right the normal
people that actually have education know
this but you watch the ones that are
ripping the posters of kids but these R
people that tell us there's 1500 genders
and I have to learn a new language to
talk to them how's everyone enjoying
this episode are you enjoying the
episode don't be
angry about whatever you're angry
about um people lose their
hair this is something that happens we
know
this in a war zone or not they lose
their hair
sucks
um I lost all of my hair and then I used
something called
keeps and it all came
back well no but seriously a lot of my
friends uh have lost their hair and
they've been able to they had great
success with this product two out of
three men are going to experience some
form of hair loss by the time they're 35
more than 50 million men in the US
suffer from male pattern baldness so
there's something called
keeps okay it is an expert recommended
hair loss
treatment it has more five star reviews
than any of its
competitors you get the quality expert
care without ever visiting a doctor's
office for a pharmacy easily subscribe
to keeps and get refill reminders so
you'll never run low on the product you
need to take care of your hair 247 care
and support low cost it's cheap but it's
good whether you're looking to prevent
hair loss stimulate hair growth or just
take better care of the hair you have
keep says you covered remember
prevention is key you want to stop the
hair from L being
lost preempt preemptively
strike if you're ready to take action
and prevent hair loss go to
ks.com Tim Dillan to receive your first
month of treatment for free and this is
great if you want to do this it really
helps the show out to to go here and and
use this not only does it work but it
helps
um keep um everybody happy with us over
at the keeps
brand
ks.com Tim Dillan to get your first
month free
ks.com Tim Dillan Jewish people
historically voted for Democrats still
do and the Democrats have been very
pro-immigration okay and recently there
have been a lot of um you know protests
happening you know not only in America
but in places like austral
where they yelled gas to Jews outside
theity the Opera House So What by the
way just so you're clear it's a massacre
that occurred in the Jewish people that
people on the left are asking for more
Massacre why are the why are Jewish
people so devoted to the Democratic
party when the Democratic party says
we're going to bring every culture into
America no matter what their feeling is
towards Jews or what their values are or
whether they like Western culture or not
why why have the Jewish people
historically been so pro Democrat well I
can't answer to immigration specifically
because everybody knows from the
Democrats or Republicans everybody knows
that we need to have some sort of an
immigration reform there's no question
about that although I got to say that
saying that there's no immigration
system that's based on Merit is also
insane because I came into the country
based on an immigration system that's
based on Merit I had to prove that I was
it's called extraordinary in field
that's how I got my citizenship which
I'm a very proud American to so you know
I do think that do you think it's a
little far though to I understand listen
college kids are nuts do you think it's
a good idea when you have the CEOs of
companies coming out and going I want a
list of all the college kids who went to
the protest I want a list of everybody
who signed this letter to the Harvard uh
Crimson whatever can I tell you
something because it does seem like it's
a little cabal Behavior well it does
seem overly paranoid and it does seem
like I I completely understand where it
comes from but I don't think it's the
right course of action to take because
it feels again it feeds into to the idea
of a cabal of a control of a yeah it's
people going I want to know everybody
who's ever disagreed with me and if a
dumb kid is 19 and goes to a protest
should they never get a job or should
they be blacklisted I got to tell you
all I'm for is equal opportunity okay
and what we have seen is the Jewish
community in the past like few years
right is that every marginalized
Community is getting uh protected is
getting people are are uh sensitive
about it there's no microaggressions
towards any other marginalized Community
everybody is very sensitive but when it
comes to the Jewish Community when it
comes to um Israel which is protected
under title six right of the human right
of the of the Civil Rights Act Right all
bets are off so right now what's
happening is the pendulum is going to
the other direction look am I for any
kind of naming names I'm absolutely not
but if somebody said something anti- um
uh racist or anti or or xenophobic or
anti or misogynistic they're going to
get repercussions and up until now if
somebody said any anything anti-semitic
there were no repercussions so I'm I'm
all for equal opportunity if you're
doing this for any other minority you do
that for the Jews as well because let's
just do you know how many Jews there are
in the world what the percentage of Jews
in the world me yeah do I know how many
Jews yeah you you have to know you don't
I would say it's 10% of 10% of the
population would of the world population
maybe
3% I I grew up in Long Island and now I
live in Beverly Hills So my answer when
somebody says how many Jews are it's
always too many because I come from Long
Island percentage of Jews in the world
is
0.18 that's wild there are okay let me
say this that's very few 14.9 or 15.1
depend on who you're count or what
you're counting million Jews in the
world so let's just go 15 right right
that's it wow that's it it's less than
the population of LA that's it yeah
that's it in the entire universe and Jew
and the Israel is the only Jewish State
Israel is the only Jewish State there 21
Arab State give us a [__] break
that's what we've been saying we're like
relax on this we are a minority we are
Mar is it okay to look at the context of
it like I fully think that the Hamas
attack was barbaric and that Israel has
a right to defend itself that's 100% the
cas does Israel have the right to exist
I believe so great then by the way to
your viewers you're a Zionist well I
don't know well but here's the thing I
will say you're just afraid of that word
has to also hang on hang on you just
let's just talk about that word for a
second because that word was taken away
from us to mean something different but
they won't let me host a Daily Show why
I don't know but if they do I'll be a
Zionist but they have to do with they
won't even give me a test they won't
even give me a test how how come what
why not I don't know what does that have
to do with being cabal no I'm kidding
talk to the cabal can I tell you one
more thing I've been saying this for
like two years I've been joking I'm like
they keep saying we have a cabal may as
well start acting like we [__] the
thing is the so the thing about being a
Zionist is like I I'm not an Evangelical
Christian because I'm I'm not going out
there being like you believe in Jes to
me Zionism is like this weird evangelism
where it's like you're going out and
telling people all the time isn't that
what it kind of is absolutely not but I
love that we're having this
conversation I've noticed in the past
like decade or so that people are saying
Zionism as if it's like some sort of an
evil Zionism is the Jewish people's
right for a state that's it okay that's
all it is and a little bit more um kind
of elaborated but is is it is it is it
is it is inherent in that the Jewish
people's right for the state to be where
Israel wants it to be wherever the
borders are absolutely not the Zionism
is a movement for Jewish Liberation and
self-determination in some parts of
their ancestral land in a Jewish not an
exclusively Jewish state so it was never
supposed to be an exclusively Jewish
it's not it is but it is pretty much an
ethnos State now no it isn't they're 21%
of Arab Israelis of Arab Israelis
Palestinians living within Israel but
they're Jewish is no they're Muslims and
Christians and they have full voting
rights full voting rights that's the
other that's the other [__] well I'm
just saying what's out there you're
amazing that's why I'm coming on the
show listen I'm coming on a comedy show
in the middle of a war so obviously it's
important right you know and I'm not I'm
not making light of anything right of
course Israel is the only country in the
in the in the Middle East where
Christian population is growing okay
Israel is not an apartheid state that
was something that has been con like the
the popul people are going to be
watching this right now and their mind's
going to go by the way I told you this
before but get ready for a a lot of hate
well listen the reality is I when people
come on I let them say what they're
going to say because this is but I love
you got to push back on I am pushing
back a little bit but I believe in in
the the ability of anybody to go and
speak freely yes and that's what I've
always believed that's what I've built
my career on so very so let me go back
people are not agreeing with you people
that are agreeing with you let me go
back to the aparte stage because your
viewers and listeners are going to freak
out right now okay within the green line
within the state of Israel what is
defined as what is state of Israel
they're equal rights one one person one
vote there are Arab Muslims on the
Supreme Court bench there's a Supreme
Court judge was in Arab a Supreme Court
Judge has sentenced the former president
of Israel to jail there are
21.8% of uh doctors and nurses in Israel
are Arabs Arab Israelis have the same
rights as Jews okay now Gaza is not even
occupied by Israel at all right so Gaza
was that was supposed to be pales
number one the West Bank is a military
control on hold been waiting to
negotiate some sort of a piece with the
Palestinians so when you talk about
Israel's an apartheid state you are 100%
wrong if you want to talk about what's
happening in the West Bank that's a
whole other conversation the people in
Gaza cannot leave well of course they
can't leave because Kamas is not letting
them out even through ra through Egypt
right but they're they're living in this
place that is kind of like a prison 100%
they're existing in these horrible
conditions 100% Israel has has limited
the type of supplies that can go in
there historically you why you know why
I don't because for years we've been
saying that Hamas has taking the supply
to build tunnels to arm and look at what
happened you know right now that they
they found out the Hamas is holding
gasoline not giving it to the population
not letting them leave didn't Israel
fund Hamas and didn't they want Hamas
instead of the pl because Hamas was more
extreme and easier to delegitimize
whereas the PLO was pushing for
two-state solution has Israel always
been interested in a two-state solution
or is their support of Hamas signaling
that they actually don't want a
two-state solution they'd rather this
crazy terrorist group controlling Gaza
so that they never have to have a
two-state solution a lot to unpack there
so um Israel uh is with along with Hamas
with Qatar with the US everybody kind of
fell into Hamas pretend game so Hamas in
their Charter is very clear and I talk
about this in my book that what they're
after is destroying the Jewish State
Jihad on all the Jews Slaughter all the
Jews except for the ones that are hiding
behind the Jewish tree and then the tree
and the stone are going to say oh
there's a Jew behind me like it's
ridiculous it's a joke it's almost it's
like a joke their Charter but that's
what they're after in recent years
they've been playing a game of like no
no no you can work with us it's fine
well we're you know we'll we'll be okay
and Israel mistake mistook this like
literally made the mistake of thinking
that they actually want to rule the
Palestinians that they're actually
interested in some sort of a normality
and they were not this was a ploy in
order to destroy Israel and what they
did in the process is sacrifice Gaza
it's believe they could destroy Israel
Israel's so they had a plan but they
Israel has so much military Supremacy
it's true but they did a
very first of all they slaughtered 1500
Israelis and mutilated bodies and raped
women so to them this is a big win right
yeah and it's very it's it's in in
incredible they were able to do that
unbelievable it's unbelievable and is
there a massive investigation in Israel
now how that look the milit everybody
woke up the military is like this it's
it's on the offense it's everybody
everybody woke up this was a very very
very very well planned up planned
operation I said this from the beginning
I'm like yeah Kamas they they uh they
put a good effort they put a really good
effort good for them but you know who
else put a good effort in destroying the
Jews Germany exactly the Nazis also put
a good [__] effort and you know who
else in the Inquisition days they also
put a good effort so every few years
some evil [__] people try to put a good
effort to exterminate the Jews and it
never in the longterm works but this was
a big thing and also remember this is
Israel and Hamas and the whole region
Hamas is a pawn of Iran and Iran
sacrificed when people say that Israel
funded Hamas what are they talking about
that's [__] Israel funded Hamas it
was like Israel allowed Hamas through
Qatar to get money because they thought
they're going to rule Gaza because
they're 2 million people there and
Israel is trying to help them to rule
these people and honestly anymore it's
not the responsibility of Israel anymore
Israel might have known just the same
way that we funded the Soviets against
uh I'm sorry we funded Al-Qaeda against
the Soviets is there any part of Israel
thinking when they're allowing Hamas or
or to get money or funding Hamas are
they going like we would rather the
representatives of Palestinians be these
crazy terrorists instead of like
legitimate people it's very look there
were elections and Kamas won right so
you Israel was given two entities kind
of going could you guys unite into one
look at the establishment of Israel
there was the ha theel and the there
were three separate kind of entities in
the yesu in the Jewish yesu that were
kind of like militant in their ways and
and trying to build the state in their
ways and David Boran as soon as the
state was funded he's like done with
everything enough with all of this
everybody underneath the IDF everybody
underneath one government One Voice one
Jewish people because the commitment of
the Jewish people was always to have a
state it wasn't to destroy anybody else
and hamas's commitment is destroying the
Jews they're not interested Hamas is is
insane and we we we know that and they
they've put the entire Arab world now in
in trouble because this is also Iran
sacrificed them basically they are the
the the the you know the slavo had he
came out and he said listen the attack
is barbaric Israel has a right to defend
himself he goes let me but he also said
there does seem to be a a knee-jerk
reaction where we can't look at context
and context never justifies anything
right but there's the context of where
this comes from yeah I I com disagree
with this vehemently well okay but I'm
saying what's out there I'm saying
what's out there that's why I'm here I
understand when you talk about context
when you talk about people from rala um
protesting peacefully and and saying
let's build Nos and let's build a
government and that's okay because what
they're after is what the Jewish yeshu
was after which is a state they're after
building something for themselves sure
Hamas is just not interested in that I
don't think Hamas is interested in that
and I I agree with you there's no
context I think the context is not it's
that there's 2 million Palestinians that
are not necessarily in Hamas right
that's that's the excuse is the
occupation quote again there's no
occupation in Gaza they this could have
been Singapore Israel has left Gaza but
the the settlement these really
settlements that are being built where
they're Built Well Golden Heights a
bunch of places right Goen Heights is is
a is a done deal but the the the whole
idea is that the UN has been roundly
critical of Israeli settlement you're
talking about the West Bank you're not
talking about Gaza because there are no
settlements in G by the way isra when
Israel left Gaza unilaterally pulled out
of Gaza in 2005 we left houses and green
houses and farms and we left everything
and you know with them they burned them
down cuz when we hear about Palestinians
going going hi I'm being evicted from my
home I have this deed that says I've
owned this home I'm being evicted from
it talking about haara we're talking
about all that stuff right we're let's
be specific I know we'll be specific
this is what Israel is criticized for
throughout the world and listen I'd
rather live in Israel it's much nicer
it's more Progressive we know that we
know the valers to live in Israel gays
women everybody 86% of Arab Israelis say
that they do not wish to live in a
Palestinian State should one gets
theocracy is never the the
of Israeli Palestinians prefer to stay
living in Israel than live in a
Palestinian State one gets but the issue
of settlements the issue of the
expansionist nature of the state of
Israel is this something that you is
there anything that you concede do you
go we've made mistakes or things have
happened that shouldn't have happened
absolutely again you know why because
Israel is the country and countries make
mistakes now when you not America
not Us Again by the way they're trying
to what they're trying to do all these
like these protest movements right now
that are yelling and screaming about the
occupation they're not talking about
occupation 67 which is the West Bank and
the settlement they're talking about the
whole thing exactly talking 1948 they're
trying to relitigate the war of 1948
that Israel didn't one didn't start and
won right right after the Holocaust okay
so that's number one in terms of the
settlement when you read my book you
understand exactly where stand
politically do I think the settlements
are great no do I think that they are
red hering [__] yeah because you're
talking about
expansionism okay and you still have to
understand that even in the West Bank
which is a disputed State it's still
under military control it never was
annexed by Israel not even under the
right-wing government so everybody's
aware that that is kind of like a limbo
area right 90% of the Palestinians live
under Palestinian rule at the areas A
and B right and in terms of numbers it's
not that expansionism when there are
about 40 450 or 495,000 Jews there and
2.9 Million right Arabs so it's not that
expansionism it's just that every time
you hear about this deed you kind of go
a deed right and people don't understand
Americans are kind of like what's with
that deed and it's terrible Isis
somebody if
some well this is this is if somebody
was living in some a place that they
owned and they had proof of ownership
well do they though I've I've seen
things where they've had Deeds saying
they own the house but even if they
didn't have Deeds the idea that you can
just go and evict somebody from a house
and and make them homeless that is seen
horrible is seen as a war crime and a
violation of international law it's it's
100% horrible but again when you're
talking about Kara specifically is a
land dispute it's a it's an ownership
dispute there land disputes right two
groups there that are that are that are
pretty extreme in their positions and
they're trying to Duke it out and they
know that this is going to cause
International uproar and again I'm not
even talking in this conversation and
the conversation we're having right now
remember there's a war going on in
Israel right now right I'm not even
talking about who did what and what the
land this has nothing to do with it this
is about people that want to exterminate
Jews period for sure I was just for sure
I was just saying that there is all of
this murkiness this has been unending
for a long time as long as I've grown up
we've always heard about violence in the
Middle East two-state solution getting
close never quite getting there and why
are we never getting there I would say
that it just the deal hasn't been made
why wasn't it made I don't know we got
very close right didn't we get very
close with Clinton under yaser arat we
got very close yaser arat was on the
plane in order to sign the deal he
received 96% of everything that he got
he landed in DC and decided to and Camp
David and said I'm not signing so when
you look
historically at what happened with
Israelis and P and again I am I come
from a liberal household like a very
Progressive household actually right
right so so when you look at the history
of this and you see how many times
Israel offered a Palestinian State and
how many times it was re rejected and
you realize that the Palestinians as a
national movement have practiced
rejectionism and you kind of go well
what do they want then and you go oh
well here's the
thing if the Palestinian as a national
movement first of all need to be called
out to be a bit more responsible that's
number one and number two if the
Palestinians would have actually been
interested in a two-state solution I'm
sure that conversation could have been
had is it a specific piece of land that
they are refusing is the two-state
solution is it just that they don't want
Israel to exist is that the whole I'm
I'm not saying they because it's not
everyone it's a certain sect of people
if you say from The River To The Sea
Palestine will be free then it means no
Isel that means Exterminating and
ethnically cleansing the Jews from their
ancestral Land from the Jordan River to
the Mediterranean Sea and we saw what
that looks like that looks like it's a
it's a exactly yeah no for for sure
Israel right now preparing a ground uh
incursion into Gaza potentially Thomas
fredman writer at the New York Times
other people who are traditionally
historically pro Israel feel like it
might be a trap it might be a quagmire
it's similar to Iraq it's quag in the
Middle East very densely populated Urban
Warfare what is the end game there I
mean I think there's something about
eight or 10 10,000 Palestinian civilians
supposedly have been killed according to
the ministry there I don't know which I
will take with a grain of salt and I'll
hurt for every child who is uninvolved
yes I there's a ton of innocent
Palestinians who've died just like ton
of innocent Israelis who've died don't
argue that um it's horrible by the way
but again the difference is the
intentionality of of of breaking into
people's homes and slaughtering and
mutilating them one to I will agree with
you collateral damage of War which is
horrible right but when you are
flattening and leveling whole sections
of a city you are aware also that you're
going to kill civilians I mean this is
true listen this is I'm I'm nobody is
for war right and again Iran by training
Kamas the way that they did and arming
them and paying them and protect you
know creating this entire kind of entity
has basically sacrificed Gaza because
this operation everybody that's involved
that planned it and executed that knew
the price that Gaza is going to pay when
there's no other choice when Israel say
and by the way when when 911 happened we
didn't know where the terrorists were I
think and we know where they are now
we've made a lot of mistakes since 911
and I think there's a lot of Advocates
of Israel that say they wouldn't want
Israel to go down the same path that the
United States went down where we got
into unwinable Wars spent trillions of
dollars we left Gaza for a reason
committed
human we didn't want to be in there
you're like here you go here are the
keys go build yourself a home build a
state any part of this ground uh
defensive concern you in terms of the
objectives and what the reality of it is
and what would be considered a victory
it concerns me very much also from
personal level um on a personal level
because I know people who will be uh
operating this uh ethereal ground
operation so I'm very personally
invested in it there is no other option
other than to eliminate Kamas there is
just no other op does that look like
it's a good question we don't know but
I'm sure the United States and Europe
and normal countries will have to help
help the Palestinians make good choices
for themselves too when Israel tells the
Palestinians leave this area or evacuate
because they don't really have anywhere
to go is that somewhat disingenuous they
do have places to go Hamas doesn't let
them go it's not this is horrible Tim
I'm not here to defend war in any level
but no but these are these are the
questions that people are asking it's
not it's not simply uh you know me it's
these are the questions that people are
asking and these are questions that I
think uh people are concerned about
they're concerned about does this
increase anti-Semitism throughout the
world does it make Israel first of all
less safe here's the thing so Israel
gave gazin two days warning okay right
Kamas didn't give Israel two minutes no
Hamas is a
barbaric terrorist organization so we
can't
compare the Govern you know we're trying
not to do we don't want to get into that
moral equivalence right right cuz there
is Hamas there is no moral equivalence
there so we're sad part about it I don't
know if you've seen there are photos of
Hamas blocking civilian cars not letting
them evacuate this is not a good thing
but you have you seen the recent uh
reports about the shifa hospital uh okay
so that is the hospital that we we claim
that in Israeli Missile hit or no no
there there two stories about the
hospital about two different hospitals
Hospital number one is the air strike
that happened last week um that
immediately there was a push
notification on every news magazine isra
bomb the hospital and 500 people died
within a second so of course we're all
like oh my God Israel does not [__]
bomb hospitals and then you look back
and you realize it was a misfiled um um
Mis launched rocket of Islamic Jihad
that landed in a parking garage and BBC
still has the tweet that says that
Israel did it still up right that's
number one but hang on the the other
thing is um that they just revealed
yesterday that Hamas headquarters is
located underneath the biggest Hospital
in Gaza
Hospital 40,000 displaced people are
there and there's a Hamas terrorist that
they interrogated that speaking that all
the visuals are online of saying yeah we
we place our headquarters underneath
Hospitals and Clinics because we know
Israel is not going to bomb there yes
that's what they do but but Israel I I
imagine has had to bomb schools and
hospitals to never bombed schools and
hospitals never never bombed schools and
hosital never I believe you but I had
Barry Weiss on the show going we have to
bomb schools we have to bomb when
they're clear and clear Israel's never
going to bomb a hospital when there
people
there headquarter it's a big problem
sure it's a big problem and here's the
thing Israel never started a war right
Hamas always broke
ceasefires Israel always had to win a
war because the only one Jewish State
like that's the reality Israel wants
peace I know it's hard for people to
understand because they're like Israel
is a big bad wolf but like I don't think
it's people that saying Israel is a big
bad wolf I think people are looking at
the situation and going what happened to
Israel was terrible what happened in on
911 was terrible the United States after
9911 went out and did a lot of things
that probably made us less safe we went
to the wrong country certainly in the
short term and we went to the wrong and
hurt our credibility worldwide
Guantanamo Bay these underground torture
prisons uh you know not following the
Geneva conventions uh these unilateral
Wars that enriched you know maybe
defense contractors but didn't make sent
a wave of refugees throughout Europe
destabilized the political situation in
Europe all of that kind of starting
after 911 I think there's a concern that
Israel in its very
understandable uh
anger in this situation could end up
doing things that are
unwise 100% yeah the difference is we
didn't know where the terrorists are
coming from right and here we know
exactly where they're at what is a post
M Gaza look like I hope it's a
flourishing beautiful Singapore ever get
the feeling that somebody's watching you
like there's somebody else in the room
now I know you're probably thinking oh
it's spooky Halloween time you're just
being paranoid but this is actually real
every single day there's actually
somebody watching your every move the
worst part is you're even paying them to
spy on you that's someone is's your
internet service provider the company
you pay for your internet every website
you visited late at night what are they
trying to say how much time you've spent
on each to keeping tabs on you and
that's why I use
expressvpn if you are using the internet
at all expressvpn is an app that allows
you to
um what it does is it scrambles the
information your router people cannot
identify these companies these data
harvesting data mining operations cannot
Harvest your data hackers cannot steal
your information how many of US Bank on
our phone how many of us have personal
information on our
phone see in the US internet service
providers are legally allowed to sell
all of your users browsing activity to
advertisers it's not just them your
network admin whether that's your school
workplace parents or whatever can see
everything you click on that could be
kind of hard to explain but with the
express VPN 100% of your traffic is
rerouted to their encrypted servers so
nobody can see a thing and my favorite
part is expressvpn is literally so
simple to use you can just open up the
app tap on the big button and that's it
expressvpn works on all your devices
whether you browse the internet on your
phone tablet computer so you can use up
to five devices at the same time under
one expressvpn subscription stop letting
people invade your privacy right now get
three extra months of expressvpn for
free when you go to expressvpn.com chim
Dillan that's expressvpn.com Chim Dillan
expressvpn.com Chim Dillan to learn more
Singapore is lovely because the cane
does work because you need a little
something you do you need a little
something I I hope they turn Palestine
into a flourishing Country Side by Side
safely with Israel Saudi Arabia and
Israel were about to normalize relations
I mean yeah and that's this was a big
plan for MBS the new Middle East the
birthplace of Islam recognizing Israel's
right to exist do you think that Hamas
chose to act when they did to destroy
that plan yes I think Iran did because
because Iran and Saudi Arabia don't
really get along they don't and sunis
and Shiites they they're big they're
Arch enemies bigger enemies than Israel
so they're using Hamas so Iran is basic
basically using Hamas Hamas is also
Sunni right right so they're using Kamas
they're sacrificing Hamas in order to
start a war with Israel so the Sunni
population in Saudi Arabia would be like
whoa whoa no no no no we don't we don't
want peace with Israel it's very
important this bond between Saudi Arabia
Israel the United States is very
important in order to alienate Iran and
Russia and all the bad actors in the
world right everybody knows yes but I I
also believe China can play very
constructive role in this will they
though I believe they could of course
they could but and I I believe that
listen we could say Bad actors and good
actors and I would agree with you
probably on some of those things for
sure but I also think that we have to in
order to avoid a larger war and more
Bloodshed we have to
enfranchise countries like China uh to
play a productive role hopefully I'm all
for it you know and I think China would
want to my godson is Chinese and
although he has Choice words about
Taiwan he's three but he's still I think
in play constructive role you living in
California you live in a
multiethnic place I live in a
multi-ethnic
place um you come in contact with people
from all over the world do you have very
interesting discussions debates I mean
very interesting about this t look it's
it's right now because you are now you
have become the focal point of this
campaign as somebody who's advocate for
Israel on in the media yeah and I
imagine that there are people that not
working for the Israeli government by in
any way or no you're just you're out
them this is your Homeland it's what
it's who you identify with you're an
Israeli person not just that it's that
Israel is the only country in the region
that's that shares our values for real
it's the only true Ally that we have
over there it's it's the stabilizing
Force but America has backed Saudi
Arabia and they have never shared our
values and America's been very cozy with
them so Iran also was going to be a
progressive country before the coup that
was sponsored by the British government
the American government and and their
intelligence agencies lot of mistakes
were made in a lot of mistakes were made
so I agree with you I I think there's a
lot of backwards uh you know countries
in the Middle East that are incredibly
oppressive and unfortunately if you look
back at the history of who propped up
some of those leaders it does lead back
of course let me just say one word about
Saudi Arabia and just people that I know
that have been there recently NBS is
trying
1,000% and I people say that it's
palatable on the street that you see
difference yeah I'm hopeful I'm a big
fan of Saudi Arabia again I live in
Beverly Hills they never had a VX
mandate or a mask mandate I felt like
you know it was you know living in a
place that you know was really cool and
I I'm a big fan of that kind of Persian
aesthetic of being not that you know
Saudis are Persians but like that kind
of very loud all four the
persianas I drive it Bentley I have you
know what I mean I I believe in that
that's the culture I believe in I'm
gonna buy Trevor Noah's Rolls-Royce
hopefully I believe in their culture I
believe in that culture of not only
having it but showing it dude I drive a
Prius I'm like literally well I mean I
mean what are you what are you producing
in treatment of course you drive a Prius
what you mentally ill um but so yeah so
let me ask you Hollywood now with they
got dueling letters and I no one's
asking me to sign either one I'll get
you on the right one can someone get me
on a letter here I'll get you on the
right one well you got one group of
celebrities going hey ceasefire you got
one group of celebrities going hey
release the hostages release the
hostages let's talk about the hostages I
agree with you let's do it there now we
know over
230 men women children there are
30 children under the age of 16
including a 9 month old a four years old
old a 12 years old a 16 years old they
were taken from their homes taken from
their parents their parents shot in
front of their faces and taken into Gaza
this is this is It's unheard of and
Kamas needs to release them immediately
now there's there is a a letter that was
signed by the biggest names in Hollywood
like Katy Perry and Justin Timber and
Madonna and and and Orlando Bloom and
grenth ptro and Chris Ro and a lot of
people galgadot and Amy Schumer and a
lot of people Jared Seinfeld and yes uh
Tiffany hadish hadish and I can continue
on and Onish hadish I know I love this
Tiffany hadish hadish she she's apparent
she's Jewish lovely um signed calling on
the release of the
hostages we purposefully did not call
for a Seas fire because you cannot
expect Israel 3 weeks after the greatest
Slaughter of Jewish people since the
Holocaust to all of a sudden go oh no no
no no no stop stop now right right you
cannot call for it calling for it it's
like literally when America went after
Isis we all agree that the world is a
safer place because Isis isn't in power
anymore right Isis has taken over like
hospitals and schools in in various
places around the Arab world right not
not slaughtering beheading right
journalists right but nobody was
standing with the stopwatch with America
and going when are you done okay SE now
nobody that's understood so no calling
for a ceasefire Israel needs to be able
to do whatever the [__] it needs to do
in order I think solve this I think what
the ceasefire is yeah is people looking
at what could what what they consider
humanitarian catastrophe and a lot of
the people that were on that letter yeah
well they have no idea their publicist
is going not just that a lot of the
people on that letter have a they have
an idea and those are people that we
know their names and they sign on to
every anti-israel [__] that's out there
okay so we like oh of course he's on it
oh of course he's on it yeah of course
like we know all these people are it's
not in like naming names it's just that
I've been in the this work for a long
time and I'm kind of like yeah Mark
Ruffalo is always going to [__] be on
the wrong side of History here always
because he doesn't literally doesn't
understand the region well so but can't
and I don't know Mark Ruffo at all and
I'm sure I disagree with him on a lot of
things I'm sure I would um you know
can't like I'm not naming names but Mark
Ruff even know if you signed on that but
I'm sure is there space for someone to
go I believe Israel has a right to
defend itself um and I believe Israel
has the right to exist but I feel like
the military operation in
Gaza will get to a point where casualty
numbers will reach such a level that it
will not only hurt the ultimate cause
because it will start turning Western
countries against Israel because they'll
go there are so many casualties now and
such a humanitarian situation and
refugees pouring into other countries is
there a room for that person who goes
I'm I'm Cur I'm cautious about the
course of action that Israel cautious
about the the course of action I'm the
one that wants a humanitarian Aid and
not like people that aren't hurt to not
get hurt more the one who wants them to
evacuate have you seen what they doing
with the water pipes they're making
missiles thank you right but they're
pulling the water I'm saying stuff
people are going to think that I'm crazy
but just look it up you knew this Tim
just knew this they they pull out the
water pipes from the from the ground the
water pipes are supposed to bring water
to their people and they turn them into
Rockets right but the two M the two
million civilians that are being
deprived of water that is a huge
sticking point for critics of Israel
going the electricity the internet the
water absolutely why didn't they build
their own water system by the way or
they po like I know the I don't know
these things do I know why they didn't
build their own War now is a disaster
I'm trying to figure out zic I don't
know why I don't even understand that my
friend looks better but now like a a
little bit of an old witch here's what
I'm saying when you when there is this
is a this is again this is again a war
that Israel didn't want this is again a
war that Israel didn't want it's and
it's it's it's just it's just I think
the people that are concerned are
concerned about the civilians and that
they should be concerned about the
hostages I said if you're calling for a
ceasefire you should also be calling for
the release of all hostages all of them
every single one of them 100% wear a dog
tag if you want it it says bring them
home now I 100% agree with I don't
really wear jewelry but I agree with the
sentiment but I 110% think all hostages
should be released absolutely it's it's
just heartbreaking and they're doing the
psychological War which they're
releasing two here and one there and
it's a [__] disaster it really is and
everybody needs to call for that so is
Benjamin Netanyahu um has this hurt him
politically has this helped him is this
is this neutral well it certainly didn't
help him he's the he's the man in charge
I the bottom line is this I don't I
don't think it's the time to talk
politics right now right if you uh read
between the lines of my work in the past
20 years you know exactly what I think
what where my policies are more or less
uh it's not the time uh he is in charge
and was in charge for the last 15 or so
years so it's always the responsibility
of the CEO at the end of the day but
it's not the time right now to discuss
this and I'm sure these conversation are
to be had after Israel gets it people
that say that Israel doesn't have a
right to exist are not in my mind
serious people but I do know that
there's a lot of them watch the comments
that you're going to be getting oh I'll
get a lot you're going to get so much
hidden you're going to get so much free
Palestine Israel next week we have heala
is coming oh fabulous it's good
we have everybody that's great no but I
I I I will say listen my next guest
right my
my Straight from Doha right now what
about Qatar that's interesting you know
Qatar is this kind of you know somewhat
westernized country that's like going
and give us a World Cup do this do that
and Hamas is living there in the Four
Seasons so I prefer um uh hania isma
hania and and uh and uh khed Masha
living in Doha than living in tan
honestly okay because there's somewhat
probably of couple of other eyes on them
there rather than in tan they'll just be
lost in [__] knows where right um I
think that qatar's role is going to be
very interesting obviously Qatar has
been extremely involved in releasing the
four hostages that were released up
until now and I can only say that I hope
they play an even bigger role I hope
that the brutality of this attack
shocked a lot of people in the Arab
world as well I know that to be um to be
the case because I see the reports and I
hope this realigns the region in a way
that's prosperous and better for the
citizens of the region and Qatar has a
big role to play here what is the
solution do you think and I mean this is
asking you to maybe predict the future
but how do we move towards a situation
in Israel with the Palestinians where we
can yeah I would like some responsible
Palestinian leadership because the
Palestinian leadership as a national
movement need to figure out what it is
that they want and what it is that
they're after they need to unite is mmud
Abbas still involved mmud Abbas is
involved he's the head of the PA he's
completing a 16-year term of a four-year
term of sentence no of of being in power
right there's been no elections yeah you
know so he's elected for fouryear term
and is completing his 16th year um but
he he is the more moderate and he I mean
other than being a holocaust Den every
now and then and saying something stupid
about the Holocaust they the Palestinian
people as a national movement so what
does he say about the hog it didn't
happen yeah yeah it's a whole thing he
had a thesis about the it was a whole
thing okay but they need to figure out
what it is that they want and I would
like to see the American left and
American progressives instead of
engaging in stupid virtue signaling on
online stupid virtue signaling activism
and bashing Israel how about holding the
Palestinians accountable too because
they think that I'm such a great
social justice Warrior and I go Israel's
terrible well yeah they don't care about
social justice they seem to care about
power uh you know women are being raped
you're not hearing about that you know
you're not hearing about the heinous
crimes that Hamas committed it's
literally cutting babies heads is not as
bad as cutting gaza's internet like
people are up in arms about the internet
being cut up I'm like there were babies
that were being cut in half right I
think I think what people are saying is
if you cut off water and you cut off
electricity and you cut off Internet you
you have a situation where you're going
to have you know I understand tens of
thousands of people die it's horrific
but you have to understand Israel is not
responsible for the citizens of Gaza
Hamas is responsible for the citizens of
Gaza right but Israel is taking certain
steps to I don't know exactly where
we're at right now Israel is always
trying to have as little amount as
casualties as possible and Hamas is
trying to have as many of them as
possible I understand that people might
look at it and think of me as some
mouthpiece of Israeli government look me
up and know that it's not the case but
I'm just saying there's there's right a
wrong in the world and Israel and the
Jewish people have a right for a tiny
State What in in closing and I do
appreciate you kind of coming on and
laying this out because I do think that
there's a lot of people that don't have
a full understanding of you know what's
going on and they're just hearing
snatches from this part one especially
when social media is flooded number one
because we're
again 0.18% or Z less than seems to a
lot of people that think about Gaza and
they go these people are living in a
Hell yep and there are Israeli guards on
the you know on standing there with guns
yeah uh there have been instances of of
of young Palestinians being killed you
know why they're guards because again
I'm going to say this again because
that's historical like that's what
happened in 2005 Israel unilaterally
pulled out of Gaza handed the keys over
to the Palestinians Hamas took over Gaza
and audah killed the Palestinians people
pal literally threw them off the
rooftops and dragged like tied them into
the cars and drove them through the
streets took over Gaza killed the
Palestinian Authority people and
basically he's been holding gazin
prisoners ever since so free Gaza indeed
free Gaza from Kamas it's a terrorist
organization it's the Taliban it's as if
you're saying I'm I support Afghan
people then I support the Taliban right
like those organization those groups
those most people that are critical of
you know outside of the people that are
just openly anti-semitic there are a lot
of them there's elected leaders in
America that are openly anti-semitic
right true that um and anti everybody
anti-white men anti- this anti that anti
everything and they're they're very
vocal about it everything is you know um
but there are people that are well it's
true it is I'm just laughing because you
find you know today with the how
Communications work you find the same
people that when when when people have
been saying hey the ecologist are
getting a little crazy a lot of the
Liberals that are now calling that out
had ignored it for years said everybody
was uh overstating it everybody has the
right for their
opinion right to speak and I'm like yeah
but they're not speaking they're calling
for a massacre there are people that are
genuinely anti-semitic there are people
that say there is not not a
justification for the attack but there
is a context with we W with what we can
put all of these things into it's an
excuse It's not context please Hamas is
not looking Hamas is not looking not
Hamas per se it's that you have this
thing if I could think of a place to
grow terrorists it would be Gaza if I
could design a place where terrorists
would become terrorists it would be a
place like Gaza is that not true right
that's because they took over by force
literally they have been controlling
that place they're not they're not even
interested in the lives of Palestinian
people I don't know what's hard to
understand here no they're just they're
just not for sure but but the fact that
they are occupying this small sliver of
pal that's a good way that's the way to
put it Hamas is occupying Gaza Israel is
not occupying Gaza right but Israel is
enforcing the the the blockade and
preventing a lot of things from getting
into Gaza and has for a long time and
Egypt as well because they're terrorists
that so the bade that Israel put on on
Gaza um periodically is always put on by
Egypt as well so but nobody talks about
that that there was a blockade of both
these countries one Arab one Jewish kind
of going Kamas is [__] and we need to
contain them and we can't let them just
get cement because they're building
tunnels we can't just let them get
gasoline because they're stockpiling it
and we the the they're they're taking
the [__] from their people in order to
fire isn't it isn't it curious for
people that Hamas is literally that Gaza
is running out of everything except
Rockets well keep throwing there was an
attack on Tel Aviv today this is the
other thing that you have to understand
the war didn't just this thing didn't
just happen on October 7th and ended it
wasn't one day there were eight
terrorists that were caught yesterday
trying to get in through the ocean there
were four that were trying to get
through the North and there are rockets
that are being launched at Israel all
the time you also have hzb and Lebanon
as well yes still today I'm talking to
my sister and she's like oh [__] siren
I'm on I'm like oh my God she's in Tel
Aviv so this is ongoing they haven't
stopped right but people are going to
Israel no no no no Israel ceasefire stop
Israel please stop and by now we're like
we can't listen to what we Israel can do
no right okay people are always going to
have problem with it and by now it's
like we just better [__] do what we
need to do
because they're gonna say [__] anyways
I'm just hoping that this uh has a as an
end game and a and a you know what I
mean because I I'm speaking from
experience of being a citizen of a
country that went on a
very long uh you know very convoluted uh
path after 911 and it we ended up
spending a lot of money I don't think we
made anyone safer after 911 I was like
you know young and all that but as an
Israeli I was watching the US going into
Iraq and I'm like the [__] are you doing
it's Iran like we knew that Iran is the
destabilizing um entity in the region
you look back at every [__] that's
happening in the world every terrorist
every everything it's all at all leads
back to Iran how did the Mad miss the
this attack oh God nobody knows there's
there was so many one of the best
intelligence agencies in the world there
was so mad isn't external though mad is
not technically look there were so many
the CIA technically external we all know
it's technically everything's external
there was how did the Americans miss it
how did everybody miss this it was there
was a major meltdown I'm well I don't
know if the Americans have have the
human Intelligence on the ground that
mad does we have great satellites we
know that we know now we're we're
starting it's become we're we're
starting to kind of break down backwards
the moves that they did and um they were
look again really good effort good
effort Kamas you're not winning this one
either but good effort right no we we
listen we don't nobody I don't think
nobody wants AAS to win except
AOC she does but um no did you see my
face how I didn't move yeah of course
try ilhan Omar see what my face does or
I mean listen they don't they don't seem
to love the Jews I mean that's just what
it is you know I mean that doesn't but
she also Al she you got to respect the
ones that come right out and say it AOC
like pretended to be Jewish ones which I
don't have a respect for she was like
I'm like started [__] it up I did a
thing about it years ago I just come out
and say what you believe that's what I
respect about you I respect that about
what Schumer's doing again I'm a Long
Island guy Catholic didn't grow up with
this around the dinner table this was
not discussed we heard about it right
but we we didn't have an intimate
involvement I had friends that went on
Birthright I have friends that are more
well-versed in it um I know there's a
lot of Muslim comedians that are talking
about it I know that there's a lot of
Jewish comedians that are talking about
I know that it's split a lot of people
and it's been a very contentious thing
if you
support democracy freedom of speech
human rights women's rights lgbtq plus
rights any kind of rights that we hold
here and you do not support Israel
within the context of the Middle East
you're a [__] idiot I think you
should support Israel within the context
of the Middle East but I also think you
should support the idea that we need to
eventually you know bring an end to the
suffering and the in the death of
innocent people and we need to somehow
figure out some type of
self-determination for Palestinians and
a life and a life for them outside of
Gaza which is a a training camp that
grows extremism and terrorism I'm
pro-israeli and also Pro Palestinian and
the these two things are not mutually
exclusive it's only on the American uh
fringes that it's presented as mutually
exclusive by the way almost all of these
towns in Kut on the on the south and the
party the Nova party the slaughter at
the party all these people are peace
activists pacifists leftwing right there
was an old lady that was in charge of
flying kites every you know the I on the
7th of October at 4M they had this thing
that they all got together and flew
kites into Gaza to show them how much
they love them like all these people are
like the lefties right and they're now
hostages and we slaughtered in Gaza so
I'm all for that again Palestinian
people need to be a little bit more
responsible and acknowledge that Israel
is there and Israel is there to stay and
stop trying to slaughter the Jews
because it ain't going to work all right
well Noah Tish B where can people follow
you and get your get this uh information
all social medias and my best one
biggest one is uh the one that I'm most
active on is is Instagram at NOA tishby
and my book is available wherever okay
hopefully we uh we'll be back on
Instagram we we we suspended temporarily
for doing a video saying the Pizza Hut
supported
Hamas my God no it well no it was just
we do wait no I'm not a big pizza fan
anyways but write them down get that put
Pizza Hut on the list thank you everyone
for listening thank you for coming thank
you so much for having me appreciate it
of course thank you